I just think it's been dope like you
know to kind of see how you've been able
to do so much from
here you've done so much since you've
gotten out and since you've been in your
current situation that kind of would
make me second guess a lot though I was
blessed to I was blessed to get a bun
and to be able to be put in this
position for sure so I be saying to
myself like
bro if I do this or you know I'm just
I'm [__]
up you see how they going about me now
so I'm pretty sure if I do anything like
just against
my probation that's my
ass yeah it's pretty interesting man
there they're on top of you for sure
you're definitely
uh and that's got to be that's just got
to be
stressful cuz at all times you know
you're kind of under a microscope it
kind of make you it kind of make you do
right it forces you to to to maybe not
make certain decisions you would have
made you think it
works yeah do you feel like
um once all this is behind you you're
going
to the same output we're
getting is that something that we're
going to continue to get are you going
to tour the country your fans haven't
seen you live for I don't even know how
long I mean you got to know if you did a
tour right now it's sold out Arenas 52
dates if if that's even something you
would even want to do you know
mhm is that something you'd be
interested in
doing going and seeing seeing the
fans a year ago I a I ain't want to if I
probably got off house it probably would
have took all the way to this time of
life for me to go on
stage that's
Ste I think that's my cheat code
standing off the
stage I don't disagree with
you a lot of artists they they they
really have they even if they don't want
to go on stage this it's you know this
is kind of how you really make money for
most artists but a lot of artists they
got great ass
music but it ain't going to go if they
don't touch their stage
right it ain't going to go if they not
on
tour you have broke that's why I was
when I said earlier like you you really
are you know an enigma when we think of
the music industry because like you said
you you haven't toured like most artists
that
are successful as you are and
uh you do have kind of like I think you
you know you you are you have a lot of
power man you have a lot of influence on
on on this industry period
I don't know a lot of people who were
dropping music the way you drop music
until you started doing it you know it's
cuz a lot of artist mind [__] a lot of
a lot of
artists they don't play the game I play
they worry about numbers I ain't never
gave a [__] about no numbers I'm part of
the food
chain raw
material um supplier then the buyer mhm
and that's all that [__] add up like
that that's how that's how when a [__]
talk that [__] I can L whip out a play n
got over 100 certifications on that
[__] so you have it don't stop there
100 it don't stop there 100 gold and
platinum records it like it like man
it's like
a what place sell food
for alberon alberon
Ralphs you see all that [__]
meat inside that freezer you know damn
well all of it ain't being bought but I
could guarantee you it's one person
walking in that store at least buying
something from each category a day yeah
and it's going to add up that's the game
you're playing I can't be [__] with I
don't disagree the hey always hey
numbers don't lie no they do not lie man
and everybody themers been played with
if you pay attention there only no more
than five artists did Big Numbers this
whole year this is true hey and I
guarantee you out of them F three of
them artists numbers was
bout I think that a lot of that is
starting to get exposed [__] it I ain't
going that R yeah I think a lot of uh
you know the stream Farms there's a
there's an artist that um you know my
boy from the label he's working cuz I do
radio so he's he works he's working his
record I know my man a ain't not one
thing scripted about me yeah I ain't got
no I ain't got nobody inside No Label no
I ain't got Jason telling me to go about
something like this
no for sure man a [__] scripted so I
know man man this [__] this [__] so real
this [__] real real life
[Music]
reality the real ones are going to stick
with me they going to [__] with me for
sure